okay well now you gave me another idea
so let's say i'm walking along the beach
yeah and i'm looking at the waves and
the sand and the sun am i supposed to
feel
or is it good for me to feel connected
to it and feel as if the waves are alive
in some manner and i'm speaking to the
rocks because in the dead end left
hemispheric
view
i see them or one would see them as
impressions picturesque impressions upon
my slate of sense so sense data pressed
upon me
but then i can and then i know that
that's associated with schizophrenias
schizophrenic
ideation in its extreme okay but then in
the other extreme i could see someone
going and talking to the rocks and and
holding them up and kissing them as that
its own form of
psychosis but i'm not sure
i don't know if that's actually
associated with schizophrenic thought
either way i want to hear so which one
should i do should i stand back
passively of you or should i treat it
somehow emulated in my brain as this is
living be curt be in this world as if
you're living engaging with it but these
are not just
plastic objects that of wood
they're they're also
not beings let's say but they're
there's something to them there's some
life that they have so how
how does one dance that web because i
can see
inane craziness on both ends of the
spectrum
but does it have to be one or the other
in keeping with what i've been saying
isn't it an error to go to one extreme
of either of these not because the
reality exists in a compromise but
because there is a wholly different
position
that is only found when you reconcile
the two opposites that is my point
and it's imaged in that taut string
but
i think
it's a very unusual view we have of the
world
that we are separate from it and it is
dead
uh and that any life in it is something
we attribute to it
i
argue and it's too long an argument to
do now i even argue that
inanimacy is
if you like the ultimate limit case of
animacy
not that animus here's some weird thing
that popped into the cosmos i think
animacy is of the essence
of a conscious universe
in different ways in different degrees
animals and animosity or are the union
animals no no as as as in things being
animated
so
obviously
yes
um but
we don't have to to go to to to that
that ext well not an extreme but but to
that length if you like um we i wouldn't
have time to justify that position but i
think i do in my book but in any case
most people at most times in the world
have not
failed to make a proper scientific
assessment and come up with a theory
that
things around them are alive they know
they're alive because they actually
experience that
and we have told ourselves that we can't
be experiencing that because it's just
not wrong isn't it i mean an age of
science
but what do we know about that actually
science is not dealing with that
question science is not
able to talk about whether there is
um
something that has consciousness or
animacy
in the world outside of our own heads
so
i don't think that one needs to
either tell oneself what's wrong when
one feels a sense of connectedness
or think that
being properly connected means
you're being being swallowed up and you
don't you know
love those waves so much that you go
into a rough scene and get drowned so
you need to keep
keep walking this balance and it's all
about the balance or harmony harmony was
the greek word and it's a word that
we've lost because i mean our world has
so little harmony in it
um things that we call harmony are
actually
dictated fiats that things must be like
this but no true harmony is is a kind of
thing that has to evolve between things
being fully themselves and
not pretending to be something they're
not so
yeah i think it i think it is a very
very important element i i wrote also an
article for the journal of consciousness
studies on the question of the self
because
i think there's a confusion you know
that
the holy person or the wise person
has no self
and i think i know what is meant i think
i can see very clearly what has meant
not a narrow egotistic selfish
um
fragmentary atomistic self of course
but
at the same time
by growing
in richness and
thinking and
meditating and creating and just being
you are growing a soul you are growing a
person you are growing fulfilling an
individual
element of the cosmos that will never be
there again and surely to say that
that's all valueless and the whole
business of existence is to try and deny
that and get as far away from it as
possible seems to me a little bit um
negative
because even the buddha um you know
had to sleep had to eat had to go to the
lavatory um if somebody shot the buddha
he didn't go well he didn't shoot me
because he did you know every everybody
has their individual self
but there's a very big difference
between what jung called
the self which is a sort of mature thing
that you grow into and the ego which is
this sort of more left hemispheric sense
of the self as the acquirer the
manipulator the one that wields power
and that's very important again
in
the
spiritual philosophies of most cultures
the renouncing of power because power is
very much the left hemisphere's major
tool it exists in order to make us
powerful to get things to grab things to
get prey to build things to make things
and thinks that we will become happier
or better in doing so although
all the evidence is very clear we don't
become happier or morally about a people
by doing it